STARTING THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET.
WE'LL START WITH THE FIRST.
WE WILL START WITH THE FIRST
TRAILER BILL ON EDUCATION AS
BEING [inaudible] SEVENTY FIVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU I'M AS YOU MAY RECALL
WE HEARD THE MAJORITY OF THE
OMNIBUS EDUCATION OMNIBUS BILL
SB -- SEVENTY FIVE LAST
WEDNESDAY HOWEVER SINCE THEN
THERE'S BEEN ONE AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL AND THAT IS TO REMOVE
THE REQUIREMENT THAT ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS RECEIVING.
AID -- FOR RELATED TO THE THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES -- WE
REMOVED A REQUIREMENT THAT THEY
MAINTAIN AT LEAST 50% OF THEIR
EIGHTY EIGHT IN ORDER TO RECEIVE --
AT FUND IF DISASTER FUNDING.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU AND THAT'S
THE ONLY CHANGE IN THE THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY GREAT -- ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE OR
QUESTIONS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
THIS RAISES A QUESTION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERE IS A SECTION ON THE EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE MASTER PLAN --
AS WE AS WE KNOW THE ASSEMBLY
HAD A BLUE RIBBON.
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION IS SPENT TWO YEARS PUT
TOGETHER PLAN.
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT IS
MISSING FROM THAT PLAN THAT IS
GOING TO BE DONE IN THIS EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE.
MASTER PLAN.
YES CERTAINLY -- SO THE EARLY
THE MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY
EDUCATION AND CARE -- WAS AS THE
HEAD CREATED TO ADDRESS SOME
VERY SPECIFIC THINGS THAT --
WILL BE BUILDING ON TOP OF THE
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION SO ONE OF
THE BIG ISSUES I THINK THAT --
AS THE ADMINISTRATION OF WE
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO LOOK AT IS --
THE DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS TO
SUPPORT LARGE PROGRAM EXPANSION --
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION REPORT
IDENTIFIED -- BUT DIDN'T REALLY
GO INTO MUCH DETAIL AS TO HOW WE
CAN CREATE THINGS LIKE PUBLIC
PRIVATE OR LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE FUNDING
FOR OVER A PERIOD OF TIME THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS.
I'M I THINK THE OTHER AT SOME OF
THE OTHER BIG PIECES ARE AROUND
THINGS LIKE HOW WE BUILD -- MORE
AT ACCESSIBLE CAREER LADDER FOR
WORKERS IN THE CHILD CARE --
INDUSTRY -- ESPECIALLY FOR
SUBSIDIZED FAMILIES SO THERE ARE
SOME PIECES AND PARTS THAT I
THINK THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
BUILDING ON THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
LOOKING FOR SOME MORE --
ACTIONABLE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
AND A PRE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
PRIORITIZATION IN TERMS OF HOW
WE FUND THOSE IN THE FUTURE
GIVEN THAT IT IS GOING TO BE.
A VERY EXPENSIVE AND HEAVY LIFT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SINGLE QUESTION THE COMMITTEE
ANY.
COME BACK TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE SINGLE PUBLIC COMMENT WE
WILL GO TO OUR NEXT BILL WE'RE
GOING TO SKIP. TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB NINETY SEVEN ON CAMPUS.
CLICK ON THE PERMANENT FINANCE --
GIVEN THAT SB NINETY SEVEN HAS
ALREADY BEEN PRESENT TO THE
COMMITTEE WANTS ALL GO HEAD AND
HIGHLIGHT -- THE ONLY TWO
CHANGES THAT BEEN MADE TO THE
BILL -- THE FIRST IS -- MOVING
THE SENSE THAT DATE FOR
PROVISIONAL LICENSE AUTHORITY
FROM JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TO JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES A REQUIREMENT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO CREATE IN
ORGANICS PROGRAM FOR
MANUFACTURED CANNABIS PRODUCTS
BY JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND ASSOCIATED CHANGES WITH THAT.
THANK YOU WE REALLY -- VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CHANGE MOVING THE
DATE FROM TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE KNOW NUMBER
OF OUR MEMBERS HAD A EXPRESSED
CONCERNS.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THIS REST.
MISTER CHAIR DO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INVOLVEMENT IN THAT
IN THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO THAT
WAS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
APPRECIATE.
THE FACT THAT OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WERE HEARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL COMING FROM
THE COMMITTEE PUBLIC COMMENT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE BAKER WITH THEIR AND RE
DISSOCIATES FOR THE FOR THE
RESOURCES LEGACY FUND WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE IN THE
MEMBERS FOR THE WORK ON THE
CHANGE IN THE SUNSET DATE ON SEA
QUEST.
AND REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
AND ONLY ZERO DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
NOW AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE REDUCTION OF THE EXEMPTION
FROM FIVE TO TWO YEARS THANK YOU.
JASON BRYANT HUMBLE COUNTY
GROWERS ALLIANCE CAMPUS
DISTRIBUTION SOCIAIS XIN WE ARE
CONTROL THE MINISTRY PRE SHAPED --
THE THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
AND WE ARE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE CROWD WENT ON WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING WITH THE TERMS OF
THE COMMITTEE HAD FEDERAL LOANS
ON BEHALF OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AS WELL AS ON ONE
CALIFORNIA -- ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE TRAILER BILL WITH THE MOST
RECENT OF AMENDMENTS.
REALLY APPRECIATED MINISTRATION
LETS THE TO COME TOGETHER ON
THIS -- BUT WE DO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S ADDITIONAL WORK TO
BE DONE SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO IN THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS.
I GETTING SOMEWHERE GOOD WORK
DONE SO THAT WE CAN AVOID AN
ADDITIONAL EXTENSION IN TWO
YEARS THANK YOU.
MARIN BANAL BEHALF OF THE UNITED
CAN AS BUSINESS ASSOCIATION THE
SANTANA CANADA'S.
ASSOCIATION.
THE UNITED MEDICAL MARIJUANA
COALITION OF SAN DIEGO THE SAN
FRANCISCO CANADA'S RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION -- LONG BEACH
COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATION THE
COACHELLA VALLEY CANNABIS
ALLIANCE NETWORK -- AND SUPPORT
THE ENFORCEMENT PIECE IN THE
BUDGET TRIBULUS CRUCIAL AND YOU
HAVE A LOT OF THE REUNIONS ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT THAT COULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MORE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT.
OKAY SEE NONE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE FIRST HEALTH
TRAILER BILL WHICH WILL BE SB
[inaudible]
SEVENTY EIGHT YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON RYAN MILLER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- THE
FIRST TELEPHONE NUMBERS TRAILER
BILL INCLUDES PROVISIONS THAT --
AFFECT.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
THE COVER CALIFORNIA --
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
BERMAN A PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS -- MOST
NOTABLY -- THE THE TRAILER BILL
INCLUDES PROVISIONS THAT
IMPLEMENT.
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE -- FOR
CONSUMERS TO PURCHASE HEALTHCARE
INSURANCE AS WELL AS THE PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE SUBSIDIES PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY COVER CALIFORNIA --
THE BILL INCLUDES -- PROVISIONS
IMPLEMENTING -- VALUE BASED
INCENTIVES -- PAYMENTS IN THE
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PROGRAM --
THE BILL INCLUDES -- PROVISIONS --
RESTORING OPTIONAL BENEFITS THAT
WERE CUT -- AFTER THE GREAT
RECESSION -- AND THE BILL --
INCLUDES PROVISIONS IMPLEMENTING
A FEW -- AUGMENTATIONS --
RELATING -- TO INFECTIOUS
DISEASES -- PREVENTION AND
CONTROL -- HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS ON THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS.
MISTRAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO
QUESTION ABOUT THE THE MANDATE
AND THE PENALTY SO ORIGINALLY
THE COUNT CONCEPT WAS TO HELP
THE PENALTY REVENUE PAY FOR THE
SUBSIDIES AND I I REALIZE THAT
WITH THE SUBSIDIES ENDED UP
BEING BIGGER THAN THE PENALTY
REVENUE SO THE STATE'S GOING
AFTER AUGMENTED BUT THAT.
THAT WAS THE ORIGINAL CONCEPT
RIGHT -- THAT WAS THE THAT WAS
THE PROPOSAL THAT WAS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND A REVISION
BUT AS YOU NOTED THE FINAL
CONFERENCE PACKAGE -- INCLUDES
SUBSIDY APPROPRIATIONS THAT ARE
IN EXCESS OF THE REVENUES OVER
THE MULTI YEAR WINDOW OKAY SO
MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER A QUESTION
THAT'S BEEN PUZZLING ME.
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE THE
SUBSIDIES GO -- THE BULK OF THEM
WERE GOING FOR HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ARE BETWEEN 40% 6100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL SO WHEN I
DO THE MATH ON THAT THAT'S FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL SIX ARE PERCENT AS
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND A YEAR AND
FOR A FAMILY OF THREE IT'S
ALMOST A HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
A YEAR.
SO I MEAN IT'S IT'S QUITE A HIGH
INCOME.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE STATISTICS
FROM WHEN THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT WAS IMPLEMENTING PENALTIES
ARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE
AVERAGE PENALTY WAS PAID BY.
A YOUNG.
ARE YOUNGER.
HEALTHY PERSON MAKING BETWEEN
THIRTY THIRTY THOUSAND AND FIFTY
THOUSAND YEARS SO HERE'S MY
PUZZLEMENT IS.
WHY ARE WE?
TAKING REVENUE FROM.
PEOPLE MAKING THIRTY TO FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND
GIVING IT IN SUBSIDIES TO PEOPLE
MAKING SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR THAT MAKES NO
SENSE TO ME -- WELL I THINK I
WOULD NOTE THAT -- LOOKING AT
ONLY THE STATE SUBSIDY COMPONENT
OF THE OVERALL PICTURE.
MIGHT LEAD ONE TO CONCLUDE THAT
I WOULD SAY THAT -- IF YOU
INCLUDE THE COMPARABLY GENEROUS
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO INDIVIDUALS BELOW
4100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL -- OUR AUGMENTATION KIND
OF PIGGY BACKS OFF OF THAT AND
SO THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE -- BELOW
THE LEVELS THAT YOU MENTIONED
ALREADY ARE RECEIVING A
RELATIVELY GENEROUS FEDERAL
SUBSIDY ASSISTANT OR NOT IF THEY
DON'T HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE.
WELL BUT BETWEEN BETWEEN TWO
HUNDRED AND 4100% FILE POVERTY
LEVEL THEY WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES -- AND AND
YELL BELOW 110038% OF FILE
POPULATE LEVEL THEY GENERALLY
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI CAL
AS WELL -- SO THERE WOULD BE A
SMALL SEGMENT THERE -- I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THE FEDERAL OR
RATHER THE FINAL CONFERENCE
COMPROMISE ALSO INCLUDED -- AND
AUGMENTATION TO PROVIDE
SUBSIDIES ACTUALLY BY SOME OF
THESE DOWN 2% FOR CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS BELOW A 138% A MEDI
CAL -- OF OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL WHO -- AREN'T ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDI CAL OKAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT APPLES AND ORANGES HERE
NOT ON ONE OF LABOR THE POINT
BUT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR
PEOPLE WHO ELECT TO BUY HEALTH
INSURANCE AND I'M SAYING IF YOU
DON'T LIKE TO BUY HEALTH
INSURANCE.
AND YOU MAKE THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR WE'RE GONNA TAKE
YOUR MONEY AND COUNTY REVENUE
AND WHERE TO SPEND IT ON A
SUBSIDY FOR SOMEONE TO MAKE
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR I I JUST HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THAT BUT I THANK YOU FOR
BEING RESPONSIVE.
THANK YOU YOU THE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEE NUMBER GOT A PUBLIC
COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE GIVEN TO
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS JUST WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING MADE AVAILABLE FOR STDS
HIV AND HEPATITIS C. IF WE VERY
WE APPRECIATE IT GREATLY THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON FOR IMITATING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I WANT TO
ECHO MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS FROM
SHE ASK ABOUT THE PUBLIC HEALTH --
FUNDING THANK YOU.
RONALD COMING HERE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA WE
CERTAINLY STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE AND THE PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE AFFORDABILITY PROGRAM
CERTAINLY WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE WE DO THINK THAT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO HELP.
INDIVIDUALS -- HAVE A EXTRA PUSH
TO TO BUY COVERAGE AND WE ALL
KNOW THAT HAVING MORE PEOPLE IN
THE SYSTEM HELPS US ALL BRING
OUR PREMIUMS DOWN -- SO WE ALSO
THINK THAT TO BE AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WILL ALSO
HELP ABOUT ONE MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO NEED ASSISTANCE
IN COVERAGE WHETHER IT'S THE
PEOPLE WE WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT UNDER A HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT WHETHER IT'S THE PEOPLE
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND SIX
HUNDRED MIDDLE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS.
WE WE ABSOLUTELY A PREACHER
PREACH A WITH THE LEGISLATURE
HAS DONE -- ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE RESTORATION OF
THE OPTIONAL BENEFITS THAT WERE
TAKEN AWAY -- AT THE TIME OF THE
RECESSION SO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE ND APARTMENT
FINANCE FORCE WORKING WITH FORD
IMPLEMENTATION THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ASK OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
RESTORATION OF CRITICAL MATIC
MEDI CAL BENEFITS THESE WERE CUT
DUE TO BUDGETARY REASONS.
AND ARE LONG OVERDUE SO DO
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE --
RESTORING THOSE BENEFITS THAT TO
MR OVER NO TEETH POINT ABOUT --
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THERE'S ALSO
LANGUAGE ADDED -- TO ON DATA
COLLECTION TO SEE WHO'S PAYING
THAT MANDATE SO DO DO APPRECIATE
THAT LANGUAGE IN THERE.
AS WELL AS THE NCO TAX --
ALLOWING THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO
PURSUE THAT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SIGNAL FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR NEXT
TRAILER BILL SB -- ONE OH FOUR
SB ONE OF FOUR OF THE HEALTH ON
OF US -- TO CONTAINS PROVISIONS
RELATING TO THE HEALTH HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND DH CS --
NOTABLY THE TRAILER BILL WOULD --
CHANGE THE FOCUS AND COMPOSITION
OF A CURRENT -- HEALTHCARE
COUNCIL -- AND EXPAND THE
MEMBERSHIP IN CHANGE -- SOME OF
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS --
THE TRAILER BILL INCLUDES -- THE
THE EXPANSION OF MEDICARE ALL --
TO UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS
BETWEEN NINETEEN AND TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF AGE -- IT INCREASES THE
INCOME ELIGIBILITY LIMIT
2110030% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL -- FOR CERTAIN SENIORS AND
DISABLED PERSONS -- AND ALSO
INCLUDES PROVISIONS -- RELATING
TO NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT -- THAT RECOGNIZE
YOLO COUNTY IS A COUNTY MEDICAL
SERVICES PROGRAM COUNTY -- AND
WITH WOULD WITHHOLD REALIGNMENT
REVENUES FROM THE C. M. S. P.
BOARD UNTIL THEIR RESERVES EQUAL
TO YEARS OF TOTAL EXPENDITURES
AFTER WHICH THEIR REALIGNMENT --
REVENUES WOULD BE RESTORED TO
CURRENT LAW LEVELS.
THANK YOU IN THE MYSTERY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE EXPANSION
OF MEDICARE ALL TO UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS UNDER AT TWO EIGHT
AGE.
TWENTY SIX ARE THOSE ELIGIBLE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ALSO ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERAL FUNDS MATCH -- AND
ACTUALLY BUT BY SHOULD CORRECT
WHAT I SAID YEAH IT'S IT'S
ACTUALLY THROUGH AGE TWENTY FIVE
OR UP TO TWENTY SIX AS YOU NOTED --
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE CURRENT.
FEDERAL.
MEDICAID PROGRAM -- UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
CERTAIN SERVICES WE REFER TO
THEM AS RESTRICTED SCOPE
COVERAGE GENERALLY THEY ARE
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND PREGNANCY
RELATED SERVICES -- UNDER OUR
EXPANSION -- NEWLY COVERED
INDIVIDUALS WILL STILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE FEDERAL
SERVICES THEY'RE CURRENTLY
OFFERED.
SO WE WILL BE DRAWING DOWN SOME
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THOSE BUT ALL
OF THE SERVICES AND ACCESS TO
RESTRICTED CODES GO RESTRICTED
SCOPE COVERAGE THAT MAKE IT FULL
SCOPE COVERAGE -- WOULD BE
FUNDED BY THE STATE GENERAL FUND.
OKAY SO -- BUT NORMALLY.
A PEOPLE IN THAT AGE RANGE THAT
WE PUT ON MEDI CAL ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR AT LEAST A 50% FEDERAL FUND
MATCH RIGHT IF NOT SOMETIMES
MORE DEPENDING ON WHO THEY ARE
AND AND WHAT THEIR ISSUES ARE.
THAT WAS ALRIGHT I BELIEVE JUST
FOR THOSE VERY LIMITED SERVICES
THAT I MENTIONED BEFORE.
OKAY SO WHAT WOULD BE WRONG TO
SAY THAT THE PEOPLE THAT WORK
SPENDING MEDI CAL TO ARE COSTING
THE STATE TWICE AS MUCH PER
CAPITA IS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ALREADY COVERED BY MEDICARE.
I'M NOT SURE THAT IT WORKS OUT
EXACTLY TO TWICE AS MUCH AGAIN
BECAUSE THERE IS SORT OF A AN
EFFECT WHERE THE INCREASED
CASELOAD -- WITH PEOPLE COMING
INTO THE PROGRAM THAT NEW
POPULATION WOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO
DRIVE DOWN THE MATCH FOR THOSE
RESTRICTED SERVICES.
BUT I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING
YOUR POINT IS RIGHT THAT THAT
THE STATE GENERAL FUND WOULD
COVER A DISPROPORTIONATELY LARGE --
PERCENTAGE OF THE OVERALL COSTS
COMPARED TO THE REST OF THE
MEDICAL POPULATION GENERALLY
SPEAKING THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
PUBLIC ON THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FARMING DATING AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE C.
M. S. P. CHANGES WITHIN THIS
TRAILER BILL.
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL -- PROPOSED SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES FOR THE SAME SB COUNTIES
AS WELL AS THE ARTICLE THIRTEEN
CAN IN BETWEEN -- COUNTIES AND
OVER SUBSEQUENT CONVERSATIONS
WITH -- THIS HOUSE THE OTHER AND
THE GOVERNOR -- WE THINK THIS
TRADABLES GREAT COMPROMISE
REALLY APPRECIATE RETURNING --
SEE MUST BE BACK TO THEIR OF
CURRENT LAW AFTER THEY'VE SPENT
DOWN TO TWO YEARS OF RESERVE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SUPPORT.
RONALD KOEMAN HERE WE HAVE A
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO IN NEAR THE
COMMENTS OF FAIR MCDADE TANG
ABOUT THE ITEM RELATED TO SAM S.
P. WE'RE REALLY GLAD ABOUT THE
COMPROMISE THAT WAS MOVE FORWARD.
WE HOPE TO SEE SAM S. P.
CONTINUE WHAT IT'S DOING WITH
THE PATHWAY TO HEALTH PROGRAM
AND PROVIDE OPTIONS TO
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHO MAY NOT FIND OPTIONS
ELSEWHERE.
ADDITIONALLY WE ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT -- THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE ON HEALTH FOR ALL YOUNG
ADULTS AND CERTAINLY WHAT THAT
MEANS TO INDIVIDUALS WE KNOW
THAT WHEN PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
HEALTHCARE IT PUTS THEM AT VERY
SERIOUS RISK TO GET.
MORE SICK -- HAVE -- MEDICAL
DEBTS -- AND IT IN IT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT WHEN WE HAVE MORE
PEOPLE IN THE SYSTEM THAT IT
MAKES HEALTHCARE COSTS LESS FOR
EVERYBODY -- AT THE END OF THE
DAY -- WE WE APPRECIATE THE
LANGUAGE CHANGES ALSO AROUND
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE AND HOPE
THAT WE CAN GET THIS EMPLOYMENT
MEANT.
IMPLEMENTED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE --
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ALL ON THAT WE ALSOSTRONGLY
SUPPORTS -- MAKING SURE THAT THE
INCOME LEVEL OF THE AGED AND
DISABLED PROGRAM IS RAISE
210038% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL SO THE SENIORS NO LONGER
HAVE A SHARE OF COSTS. FOR THEIR
COVERAGE THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT RAISING THE MEDIC HOW
AGING DISABLED INCOME LIMITS OF
THAT.
HI SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITY ARE NO LONGER SUBJECT
TO A LOWER INCOME ELIGIBILITY
THRESHOLD SIMPLY DUE TO THEIR
AGE OR DISABILITY STATUS SO --
DO APPRECIATE THIS LONG OVERDUE
FIX -- WE ALSO APPRECIATE --
EXPANDING MEDICAID I'LL.
TO UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS UP TO AGE
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PACE
THE PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
AND THE PROVISION THAT ADJUSTS
THE RATE SETTING MECHANISM FOR
CAL PACE THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HERE TO SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF THAT MEDICAL TEN
DOCUMENTING ADULTS THINKS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NOT SEEING ANY MORE ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE LAST ITEM ON THE AGENDA
IS B. ONE OH SIX WHICH IS THE
AMENDMENT TO OUR BUDGET ACT --
SB ONE OF SIX CONTAINS
AMENDMENTS -- TO HEALTH AND
EDUCATION PARTS OF THE ORIGINAL
BUDGET BILL -- REGARDING --
HEALTH CARE AT THE TRAILER BILL
WOULD REVERT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OF FUNDING THAT WAS --
FORMALLY ALLOCATED TO THE
COUNCIL ON HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SERVICE SYSTEMS AND RE
APPROPRIATE THOSE FUNDS TO THE
NEW -- HEALTHY CALL CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL COMMISSION THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN HEALTH ON THE BUS TO
THAT WE JUST DISCUSSED.
JUST CALL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE OTHER TWO
AMENDMENTS ARE TRULY VERY
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS -- BOTH THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD AT POLICY
COUNCIL WHICH WAS -- CREATED IN
THE EDUCATION OMNIBUS TRAILER
BILL -- AS WELL AS THE MASTER
PLAN FOR EARLY EDUCATION -- IN
THE BUDGET BILL THEY WERE PUT
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
BUT WE ARE NOW ALIGNING THEM TO
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WHICH IS WHERE THEY ENDED
UP IN THE OMNIBUS BILL SO IT'S
VERY MUCH A TECHNICAL CHANGE.
THANK YOU ANY.
QUESTIONS MISTER WATER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAD A
QUESTION ABOUT THE FUNDING FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH IT SEE A UC
AND CSU WHICH I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TRAILER BILL
HAS SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THAT MAKES
IT CLEAR THAT -- IN THE CASE OF
THE UC ALL OF THAT IS FUNDING.
IN STATE TUITION -- IT I'M SORRY
IN STATE A RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
GROWTH AND NOT OUT OF STATE --
ENROLLMENT GROWTH BUT THE UC
IT'S KIND OF SPLIT I'M SORRY --
YOU THE YEAH THE UC IS KIND OF
SPLIT THERE'S FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THAT SPECIFICALLY
EARMARKED FOR IN STATE AND THEN
THERE'S TEN MILLION TO CONTINUE
THE ENROLLMENT GROWTH FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS I'M WONDERING IF
THAT TEN MILLION.
IS ALSO IN STATE ONLY.
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH FINANCE IT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT IS
IN STATE AS WELL OKAY THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
COULD NOT SEE ANY ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE APPRECIATE
THE ADDITIONAL SUBSIDIES
PARTICULARLY TO YOU IS THERE OUT
THE PREMIUMS FOR INDIVIDUALS.
BELOW A HUNDRED AND 38% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL AND THESE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR FOR MEDI CAL EXCEPT -- AT
PERHAPS THEY THEY ARE I CARE
GIVERS AND SO I DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH FOUR QUARTERS FOR FROM
MEDICARE AND SO -- WE DO
APPRECIATE DURING OUT THESE --
PREMIUMS FOR THIS LOW INCOME
POPULATION THANK YOU.
RONALD COMING HERE WE HAVE HELP
TEXAS CALIFORNIA ABSOLUTELY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE OF SIX
WE ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
INCLUDED -- VERY MUCH FOR THE
REASONS MY AND MY COLLEAGUE AT
JUST SAID FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
UNDER A 138% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL WITH INCLUSION OF
THIS WE ARE NOW SEEING ABOUT ONE
POINT.
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS GOING TO
CALIFORNIANS OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS FOR THIS PROGRAM AND WILL
DO A LOT TO HELP MANY
INDIVIDUALS BOTH UNDER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT AND FOR
THOSE ABOVE TWO HUNDRED GOING UP.
TO SIX HUNDRED STILL A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO ON A HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT TO TWO HUNDRED BUT LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT WAS DONE -- ON THIS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
OKAY NOT SEEING ANY JUST WANNA
JUST ANNOUNCED THAT ALL THESE
BILLS EXCEPT. FOR THE CANNABIS
TRAILER BILL WILL BE HEARD ON
THE FLOOR WHEN WE CONVENE AT ONE
PM -- WE WILL ALSO.
SO WE STILL HAVE A COUPLE ITEMS
THAT WE STILL HAVE OUTSTANDING.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH
AROUND HOUSING.
AND WATER.
AND TO THAT WILL BE IT FOR TODAY.
BUT THAT WE ARE TURNED